Sarah Wagenknecht lädt zur großen
Friedensdemo und alle sind gekommen
linke rechte Verschwörungstheoretiker
Putin Freunde normale Leute Schwaben und
damit es auch ein bisschen seriös wird
bin auch da der heute schon
Friedensbotschafter
warum sind Sie heute hier
[Musik]
hallo für Knecht als Kanzlerin
ja da muss ich auch lassen
[Musik]
weiß ich gar nicht mehr viele von denen
die sich heute Links nennen ob da nicht
schon die rechte anfängt
wie war denn die Stimmung heute hier auf
der Demo sind sie zufrieden haben sie
keine Augen keine Ohren sie haben ja
organisiert ja wie die Stimmung ist die
Stimmung ist sehr friedlich sehr heiter
gewesen
aber wollen sie jetzt noch länger mit
dem Schärfen weil ich habe noch ein paar
Termine
werden Waffen sind zum Töten da und du
sonst nichts ja und das Töten aber wenn
wir der Ukraine keine Waffen liefern
würden dann würde sie ja nicht mehr
existieren oder das sehe ich ein
bisschen anders in meinen Augen ist die
nato-ost-erweiterung die Wurzel des
ganzen Übels ich habe mir tatsächlich
genommen ich wollte immer ein Schnaps
trinken wenn jemand sagt die NATO ist
Schuld damit ich auch ein bisschen Spaß
hier habe ja dann
von mir
danke danke
versprochen die NATO erweitert sich
nicht Richtung Osten
die USA und die NATO sind Schuld richtig
[Musik]
allgemeines Kriegs besoffen wenn man
sagt dass die Ukraine ein Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung hat
ach nee sind sie eine Satiresendung
ja ich frage ganz ehrlich
eine satirische Veranstaltung ja
inwiefern ja schon sehr viele Leute die
auch der NATO die Schuld geben wissen
Sie sie langweilig und es geht auch
nicht um Heere Werte in diesem Krieg
sondern um die NATO und den Umfang der
amerikanischen Einflusszone da gibt's
die Seite von Monkey works und wenn man
die beobachtet wie heißt die Monkey
works das sind die die das aufgedeckt
haben
mit der Pipeline das bringt auf jeden
Fall seriöser als tagesschau.de
wie viel Prozent ihres Territoriums
müsste die Ukraine abgeben für den
Frieden
es ist eine weg also das ist der
Geopolitik es ist Geopolitik dann müssen
wir uns nichts nichts einbilden zu hoch
für den einfachen Bürger für den
einfachen Bürger
also ich würde sagen gar nichts abgeben
aber gut zu hoch für den einfachen
Bürger sind Sie heute hier hingekommen
von Hamburg richtig
der ist auch das stimmt komm mal rüber
junge nein nein das ZDF also ich bezahl'
zum Beispiel kein Zeit mehr so
ich habe sicher wahrscheinlich in die
Kamera dass wir ihr Gesicht haben aber
ich gehe lieber ins Knast ja als dass
ich also weiter bezahlt für die Lügen ja
so ist das ja
das ist der Mann ne da kommt dann jemand
vorbei bei Ihnen
besonders
[Applaus]
sonst setzt es was